so when someone says education quality
is bad cut teachers on teaching you
don't want to say okay teachers on
teaching you wanna say well why don't
they teach you oh because they're not
being monitored well why are they not
being monitored or because the
politicians don't care well why do the
politicians not care because people
don't care why do people not care in
fact there's a true that people don't
care maybe they do but they simply don't
exercise their political rights through
the system so you know you get a very
different process for us it's really
important that you spend time getting
the diagnosis done because guess what if
you don't do that your diagnosis right
your solution which is step three for us
to design will solve the wrong thing
it'll be the band-aid it won't be the
correcting the internal trauma if that's
what you're doing so it won't be a
sustainable solution boom what's up
everyone welcome to simulation I'm your
host Don sake and we are at the Harvard
Kennedy School in the beautiful
Cambridge in Massachusetts we are now
going to be talking about economic
development and empowerment we have
awesome quadric joining us on the show
hello hi thank you so much for coming on
greatly appreciated and pleasure to be
here yeah awesomes work so interesting
he's the professor of international
finance and development at Harvard
Kennedy School he's the co-director of
evidence for polity policy design epod
and co-founder of the Center for
Economic Research and Pakistan CERP
starting July 1st 2019 he will serve as
a director of the Center for
International Development CID at Harvard
University all right awesome let's start
things off with the perspective of we're
stewards of Earth now what is your
current take on the state of our world
start with the easy question yeah so I
guess the two ways to look at it one way
is kind of more the arc of history if
you will and if you look at the arc of
history in terms of particularly if you
take the view of economic development
actually things are really good in terms
of things like education levels maternal
mortality health outcomes kind of what
you would think as the basic ingredients
you know are people able to consume the
basic stuff what does poverty rates
looking like like all these simple
measures but powerful measures of
economic development and empowerment
actually things are the progress we've
made in the last 50 to 100 years has
been just spectacular so in that sense
you know you know things are great that
said obviously a lot of us don't feel
that way
and so it would be kind of naive to say
well look at the data clearly we're much
better than our forefathers were and so
we should all be really grateful and
thankful about that in reality as you
can see in the world there's a really
concerning trend that people are not
unhappy right the kind of promise of
globalization hasn't quite given people
what they expected there was a
resentment
there's polarization there's increased
xenophobia we aren't a great kumbaya
place we aren't a place where everyone
is like thrilled with how they're doing
everyone's opening up to others
increasingly if anything populism is on
the rise we don't want people to come in
from outside we don't want to share what
resources we have and other people are
very dissatisfied there see their
forefathers not in terms of I'm better
than what my father had I have a
flat-screen TV now I can eat comfortably
now but they see themselves relative to
where they could be or where they think
they could be in terms of ranks and that
creates a lot of unhappiness and so so I
think I think if you ask me kind of what
the pressing problem of our time is is
to really pay creed to that sentiment is
to take it seriously to not dismiss it
and try and figure out how is it that
despite the economic progress we've made
these forces are still there are they
real or are they also driven just by a
greater global awareness are we just
more sensitive to these things now and
even if it's all in our mind it still is
real right emotions are real emotions
are palatable beliefs are real
aspirations are real expectations are
real and divergence from your
expectations or aspirations Israel
because it leads to real behavior and
some of that behavior is not the
behavior we as humankind would aspire to
we want to be a place where we provide
opportunities for others we're not
unhappy with other success we want to
share another success we want to help
people who are worse off than us become
better and that's the world we aspire to
and so in that sense I think that to me
would be kind of a pressing problem now
as an academic as a researcher is also a
practitioner you know I don't I don't
get discouraged it's not you know yes
these are these are challenging
questions but I do think increasingly we
have the two
the information I mean we live in an
amazing era of you know if you gave me
access to your phone I probably know
more about your life than you do scary
as well but it also says that there's a
possibility that we have more we know
now more about the human condition than
we've ever done before now it's the onus
is on us to use that in a way to improve
our lives and when I say our I don't
mean our personal lives but I mean our
collective lives yet the the state of
the world being so so successful in so
many ways of measurement while
simultaneously seeing so many things
that are like why do we have those
errors happening and how do we fix them
and one of the solutions that you name
there is this interdependence on one
another and building systems that really
uplift the collective meet basic
physiological needs make the
self-actualization transcendence even
more commonplace so that we can reap the
creative fruits of all people now
awesome now teach us about the journey
that you went through in order to be
able to get to this point that's a it's
a great question I guess we all have you
know we all have our personal journeys
and I think a lot of us we do what we do
partly because of that personal journey
and it's very true for me as well and so
for my for me the personal journey was
so suggest that you know I I was born in
England my parents were doctors they
were originally from Pakistan they were
working in England I spent my childhood
in Nigeria my parents had a drive to be
in the world they decided they were
going to work in Nigeria so I spent all
my childhood actually amazing years in
Nigeria northern Nigeria in a place
called Cano as an adolescent I moved to
Pakistan so I did kind of my I would say
my sort of middle to high school
education in Pakistan
again sort of an amazing experience
challenging times but an amazing
experience and then I came as an
undergrad to actually Cambridge not
Harvard a place down the road which
Harvard makes fun of called MIT but I
love both places and I never left I did
my PhD at Harvard
and I joined the faculty here how did
the transition happen from Pakistan to
Cambridge how did you find that that's a
great so you know so the one thing that
has worked for me and I'll say a couple
of things and some might side contradict
Lisa but I'll explain why they're not so
one of the things I've valued and I got
from my parents very much and it's part
of their journey as well and as part of
my family's journey and my personal
journey is investing in human capital it
was always about that the way you would
kind of move to the next stage in life
was you really invested in education and
for me kind of applying to the u.s.
there were good places in Pakistan as
well but nothing compared to the kind of
places you could get here and so it was
all about trying to do the best you can
in that educational journey and
sometimes a great personal cost I mean
all my siblings I have two other
brothers all of us did that and you know
my parents I sometimes feel you know the
best gift they could have given us was a
very costly gift for them it was a gift
of Education and human capital but it
also meant a gift of mobility you know
my parents stayed back all their kids
are spread out in the world and you know
I give them a lot of credit to say that
look I'm not going to hold them back to
me you know there's the insecurity you
want your kids to be with you but you
know you if you invest in people guess
what happens they move and so for me it
was very clear that human capital was
very important these are the two lessons
I learned and again I credit a lot my
parents and my grandparents for this as
well is kind of two realizations the
first is even though hard work matters
and education matters most of what
successes in chairman buy is just luck I
was just lucky I was lucky to be born in
a family which was reasonably well off
my parents were doctors my grandparents
were professionals you know so there was
in a country where you know the vast
majority of people can barely I miss and
those times had barely enough food to
survive I had the luxury of being able
to invest in human capital now was just
luck
and also just their attitude right the
friends I found in life who guided me
the mentors I found a lot of these
things you can expose look at them and
say no no but there was some strategy
here I really think maybe but mostly it
was just I was there at the right place
at the right time I was born in the
right place
and the reason I kind of mentioned this
is I'm not saying hardwork doesn't
matter but the majority of what
describes a variation in your outcomes
is luck and then once you land in some
place of course you can have a positive
trajectory based on your investment in
human capital but because you realize
it's luck then the third lesson is very
obvious which again comes to me from my
parents my parents were doctors and I
remember as a child I would really big
grudge like the patient always came
first right we wouldn't be going out
somewhere my dad's an ophthalmologist my
mom's a gynecologist you know and
emergency would come and it was never a
question of saying kids sorry but I got
to do this
both my mom and my dad and I you know as
a child you resent that but as you grow
older you realize what message they were
telling you that what matters is not
your personal individual happiness but
giving to others and so you know I vowed
never to be a doctor because I was like
man this is this takes over your life
although in a very ironic way I've ended
up being a different kind of doctor and
equally as obsessed I would say in a
good way about making that difference
but I think that that's really poignant
because or-or-or is really powerful
once you recognize that most of life is
luck then you feel like it's your
responsibility to have whatever
resources you have because they're
produced by luck like what you have is
not just you know you you shouldn't feel
ownership even if you think you got it
yourself through your hard work you
should realize most of it was a gift
given to you and with the gift given to
you then it's your responsibility to
share that gift with others and whatever
way you can and so that's that's really
being a driving force in a lot of the
work that I've done and a lot of people
that I'm impressed by who have lived
that if we stand on the shoulders of
giants absolutely 100 billion people
that build civilization before us
absolute and also makes sense now with
understanding the journey that you went
through a very globalized journey with
parents that were both putting other's
health first and that that makes sense
now for me to better understand who you
are and hopefully others as well awesome
now teachers teach us about these three
evidence for policy designed epod center
for economic research in Pakistan SERP
and the Center for International
Development CID one thing here that is a
common thread that I've seen is that you
are using scientific evidence to show
how to best develop economies and
maximize people's potential absolutely
so you know so I trained as an economist
and so for me I'm not necessarily making
a blanket statement of area I'm just
describing how I found the world really
a way to contribute to the world using
my own ability so I was trained
initially as an engineer so my approach
the world as an undergrad I was you know
did math computer science and economics
but you know I very much had an
engineering view of the world what I
like about engineers is is in some sense
and I don't want to offend engineers who
are rail engineers I became an economist
is there's a simplicity in how they
approach things which i think is
beautiful and the simplicity is you
start with a problem you face and you
don't necessarily theorize or
philosophize about it endlessly you kind
of for yeah there's a very practicality
to it there's a problem I gotta fix it
right and then you realize that you're
fixed to the problem the Machine you
make to solve the problem isn't perfect
it's never gonna be perfect that's fine
but you still build the machine and then
what you do is you kind of run the
Machine and you see how it does and as
you operate the machine the kind of you
figure out which parts are working what
are not working and you keep adjusting
and iterating what I find in policy
making or economics if you will is very
similar to that approach you you analyze
a problem you then say okay I'm gonna
try and design a solution to this
problem I'm gonna diagnose first of all
I'm gonna figure out what's causing this
problem then I'm gonna try and design a
machine a solution it'll be a policy
reform now the role of evidence or
analytics is critical in this because
you can't while it's important to use
human intuition look how big I'm a big
believer in the power of the narrative
the power of intuition the power of
personal perspective but that's the
initial driving force if you only rely
on that you can lead to all sort of
biased decisions I think this is the
right policy because I believe in it and
that's dangerous
so having that initial inspiration start
you off but then marrying it with
analytics which to me is both theory and
data is critical because that keeps that
machine running well it keeps that
policy adjustment that you need to do
based on real hard evidence and what
often when I say hard evidence people
think we're you're an economist you're
obviously gonna use like quantitative
stuff only but increasingly and that is
a weakness but by the way I acknowledge
that but increasingly we're able to use
qualitative analysis well so for me the
framework is not about I'm running a
regression or doing some really big data
type of stuff it's just that I'm being
analytical logical consistent in how I'm
adapting iterating and improving my
policy and I think that becomes
fundamental the three organizations you
mentioned all sort of typify all exactly
that approach let me start with iPod and
SERP because they're both kind of sister
organizations I bought in a more global
scale SERP at a country specific skill
sir pretty operates in Pakistan and you
should think of iPod and SERP having the
same mission except SERPs view was look
a country like Pakistan it's huge 200
million people still doesn't have as
much evidence-based decision-making in
policy I mean the u.s. is amazing in
that sense of developed countries at how
much solid scholarship you have about
any policy reform you can think of a lot
of countries like Pakistan and other
developing countries don't have that and
so Serb for us was with a bunch of my
colleagues several faculty members who
are kind of like me who are from
Pakistan art left me at Princeton Ali
Chima at lungs in Pakistan Adnan Khan at
LSE in London the Highland Rabi at
Pomona that we bunch of people got
together we said we got to build
something like this in Pakistan and
that's been a fruit of love where for
the last ten years or so we've really
pushed both in terms of creating
evidence for policy training
policymakers training future researchers
interfacing with decision makers or the
whole gamut and you know I'm thrilled
that that organization has recently
moved to stage two where the founders
people like us have stepped back a bit a
new leadership is emerging to kind of
scale that organization our
I bought is very similar a pod was set
up by Rohini Pandey and Reema Hana and
myself kind of three academics who work
in different parts of the world but the
same idea we wanted to have you know
we're sitting at the Kennedy School so
for me it was really important to say
you know evidence should be useful it
should be applied we stood up to policy
school and so we should really try and
be at the same if you will not just
design table but the problem discovery
table as a policy maker we have amazing
people who are students of ours some
younger some older who are actually
driving policy change in their countries
we need to somehow have a partnership
with them where the two of us are in the
same table working together towards this
journey and that's just been spectacular
and I'm really grateful to have been
part of that in different countries if
you could look at iPods work and I
welcome people to do so online you'll
see kind of some of the examples of how
these engagements work CID is is the
parent of epod we were all part of CID
I've now had you know people think it's
an honor but I think of it as a as a as
a heavy responsibility burden perhaps is
a harsh word to use of Rhys I will be
starting as director for CID in July and
I'm taking over from Ricardo Hausmann
who's done an amazing job as a leader
for the loss actually almost decade and
a half and what I view kind of CID is
very much that first thing I said to you
which is you know if I think of what one
of the biggest assets that I'm sitting
on right now the biggest gifts if you
will is that I'm at Harvard and I don't
mean that in an arrogant way I mean that
in a way that Harvard is one of the
unique places to me and whether it
deserves it or not as a different
question but which has amazing influence
in the world in fact it has amazing
global convening power so it's not just
Harvard has amazing set of faculty and
students which it does it's just some of
the most impressive people I've met here
have been sort of in might in my years
over here but what I find amazing is it
is able to draw other talented people
into it even if they visit for a bit
even if I get faculty from other
universities that come in and worked
and so so my vision for CID is really
that we should leverage global talent in
the world to solve some of the most
pressing problems that the world faces
today it's a very simple vision but I
feel like it's a vision where we're
increasingly at Harvard or enablers
we're doers as well some of the work
we'll do ourselves but mostly we enable
the best the most talented people in the
world to connect with those who have the
most needs and make that work happen in
the same framework in the same
analytical evidence-driven style of work
and that's what I'm most excited about
whether I'll succeed or not we've
already
I think achieved somewhat on this but
you know I'm I want to keep growing and
so you should ask me in a few years how
it's going that's that's the intent okay
so I want to now learn from you about
the the exact practices of policy design
across the world that you have
implemented and scientifically analyzed
when you when your team gave a talk at
effective altruism global in Boston we
were able to learn that there's a
specific way to deliver
insecticide-treated Nets for insects
from specially mosquitos in Africa and
how it was crazy seeing over 15 years
the amount of cases just decrease of
malaria and I would love to learn about
deeper these specific yeah cases and how
you've been analyzed great so let me
give you so the insectivore one is is
probably work done by JPL which is great
the poverty action lab at MIT and
they're doing some wonderful work as
well this let me answer this in in kind
of both the micro and the macro of it
the microwaves kind of specific examples
of projects projects I've been involved
in and projects colleagues of Mines have
been involved in so I'll give you three
examples of the micro and then I want to
kind of take it at a macro level to say
what's what's the template over here
what's how do we get to scale this up so
that it's not just us doing it but many
others can do it as well at their micro
level start first with my own work
because I know it better so just one
example of my work is I've been doing
work in education now in in Pakistan for
the last almost two decades and in that
work we started very much
with what I would call a input based
approach like the approach was figure
out specific things which are not
working like you know new schools lack
good teachers or do schools lack good
textbooks or and that's very much what
the literature has done and then and
this is the revolution the empirical
revolution that people like Esther Duflo
and Abhijit Banerjee and Michael Kramer
and others spearheaded which is kind of
randomized control trials be very
scientific about what you're doing test
these inputs see what happens when you
randomly I look at these inputs to one
group and not the other just like you
did in medical drug trials and there's
been a profound set of knowledge that
have been created from that that's very
much the approach that we started with
but increasingly we have at least in my
work I've changed slightly in the sense
that rather than my concern with with
inputs is that what if you don't get it
right right what if you don't know in
this environment what's the right input
and you could you could try different
ones and navigate that way and that's
one way to go the way we went is mostly
because of my own background which is I
am an industrial organization person as
well and so so I viewed schools and
parents and teachers as very interesting
actors and so one of the views I took is
to say well if the actors are there and
a lot of the times I saw in parks and
the actors wore their parents did want
schooling for their kids kids didn't
want to improve teachers as long as they
were rewarded appropriately did want to
teach better schools did want to provide
good quality education as long as again
they're rewarded and recognized for it
and so a lot of the work that I've done
now together with additional doses at
the World Bank and Dyer and Rob use of
Pomona under the name of leaps learning
and achievement in Pakistan schools is
understanding what are the frictions
that prevent these actors from achieving
success so every one of our projects now
has really resolved one or the other of
these frictions it could be
informational frictions I as a parent
don't know what schools are good or bad
it could be financial frictions I as a
school can't get money to grow it could
be labor market frictions I as a school
can't hire good teachers or
or them it could be educational
intermediary frictions I as a school or
as a parent can't buy educational
support services like extra coaching or
teacher training or eLearning and so let
me use the word frictions exactly it's
it's exactly that and so that approach
touchwood has been working really well
and now we're scaling it up to kind of
do it at the economy-wide level so
almost think create a virtual
marketplace create a virtual Marcus like
it's Amazon meets eBay where you know
parents and teachers and schools and
financial providers and educational
support service providers can all meet
together and kind of exchange and so
that's been one approach let me mention
briefly two other projects not of mine
but I think these are amazing and just
quick just to make sure it's clear the
so then these these key players will
meet and talk about their best practices
for decreasing friction and then they'll
apply them exactly so they will because
they we're enabling them to act
basically and as long as this the nice
thing about this approach is that as
long as their preferences are in the
right way they will achieve success test
scores will go up school fees will grow
up education quality improve and every
one of our projects we see that
happening right so I'm not saying look
sometimes it is the case at preferences
may not be progressive parents may not
want to educate girls you know there are
situations like that where this approach
would need more nudging but by and large
I've seen most actors do want the best
for their kids parents do teachers do
and so so I think as a first process a
lot of room to be made of improvement
just by enabling actors I want to
mention Rohini Pandey and Reema Hanna's
work which is both as just spectacular
Rainie has been doing some amazing work
in India and environmental regulation in
a very similar spirit to this work
trying to think about not just one
example try to think about how do I work
with regulators and environmental
agencies to have a much more systematic
design based process through which they
can improve regulation and her work has
found huge impacts just by doing simple
design tweaks and well not that simple
but you know reasonably feasible design
tweaks finding amazing work
similarly Rhema HANA with co-authors of
hers at MIT been Tolkien and Abhijit
Banerjee had done some spectacular work
a series of papers on improving
targeting of subsidies in an Indonesia
so again how do we use evidence and
design to better target subsidies that a
country may be giving its poor people
there's a whole bunch of papers I'm not
going to summarize them but all of this
work and let me now go to the macro
point each of this kind of work
typifies one specific style of working
and we've kind of codified that in what
we had he pawed called speedy smart
policy design and implementation and
this is just one manifestation of this
work I'm not necessarily saying well
this is the only way to go but it let me
explain it to you because it'll
highlight how we're able to be
consistent and how evidence and
analytics can be brought in so what we
do in speedy is we kind of have the
following steps so first we want to
identify the problem and this is
non-trivial lot of times we focus on
problems which are not really the
problems we do kind of superficial
problems so to give you an example in
education my problem is enrollment okay
so I might ask a Minister of Education
or a sector of Education why is
enrollment - your problem you might say
well it's because I want better jobs for
my people or I want better civic nests
and you say what wait a second is your
problem enrollment or is your problem
getting the type of education which
leads to personal improvement and those
are different problems because the first
problem you just get kids in school
the second problem you have to make sure
that not only do you get kids in school
but they're learning the kind of skills
that would help them in life yes so
quality comes in not just in role yes so
the first step for us is getting the
problem right the second and by the way
each of these steps is done in tandem
with researchers and practitioners and
people in the field it's not like any
one of us has a right to decide that we
all collectively have that discussion
you're poking with the question why
deeper wise well that comes next so
that's exactly right so once we know the
problem then you want to do it what we
could call in medicine and differential
diagnosis why is a problem occurring you
keep asking why and you want to go
beyond the kind of superficial diagnosis
if you if you were a patient in you who
were bleeding and you walked into a
doctor and you said hey doctor what's my
problem
the doctor said will you're bleeding
you're gonna laugh exactly what you just
did right you're gonna laugh and say
well that's that's it and then the
doctor says even worse and by the way
here's some band-aids I stopped the
bleeding thank you so much
check please leave right a good doctor
would say whoa wait a second why you
bleeding yes is it an external injury is
an internal hemorrhage if it's internal
hemorrhage which organ is hemorrhaging
why is it hemorrhaging so you want to do
the same in policy so when someone says
education quality is bad cut teachers
aren't teaching you don't want to say
okay teachers aren't teaching you want
to say well why don't they teach you or
because they're not being monitored well
why are they not being monitored or
because the politicians don't care well
why do the politicians not care because
people don't care why do people not care
in fact is it true that people don't
care maybe they do but they simply don't
exercise their political rights through
the system so you know you get a very
different process for us it's really
important that you spend time getting
the diagnosis done because guess what if
you don't do the diagnosis right your
solution which is step three for us to
design will solve the wrong thing it'll
be the band-aid it won't be the
correcting the internal trauma if that's
what you're doing so it won't be a
sustainable solution it might work for a
bit in fact you don't want to actually
the joking bleeding is the first thing
you want to do is actually stop the
bleeding
this is already but you don't stop there
right especially if you have a lot of
bleeding going on you don't want the
patient to die from the superficial
cause right so it could be that you
solve that but there's a deeper analysis
you guys go to the roots exactly the
root causes if you will that's step two
for us step three is design now you
become the engineer now you say what's
the policy machine what's the thing I
need to make to solve this and to solve
not the problem but the deeper diagnosis
you just did step four is even if you
can design it was a quick idea of what a
design what design would look like so so
let me continue the education example so
suppose I found out that the problem was
that there's really political the
teachers are not present teachers on
present pose areas and bureaucratic
pressure there's a bureaucratic pressure
because there is a political pressure
but parents care then you've said the
deeper diagnosis is somehow parents are
not being able to express their concern
politically through the system so a
design would be and this is something I
mentioned this kind of hypothetically
but it's actually something I'm working
with a political
this Tiffany Simon who's a PhD student
used to work with me in Princeton
she and I are proposing this pilot
project we're in Pakistan were going to
go to households and see if we can get
their preferences better politically
express yes so how do you get people to
lobby for something if that's the deeper
can say and I know if that's true or not
but that the design we're gonna do is
basically effective ways we can examine
for parents in rural areas to express
their unhappiness with their school in
their village to either their local
politician or central politician or the
local bureaucrat or the central
bureaucrat I mean how do you how do they
get engaged exactly so so so what we're
gonna do is to say what is the right
form of engagement what is the right
messaging so it really is political
activism but in a way that we examine
different ways so for instance is the
right thing for you to do is all get
together and have a meeting with the
local bureaucrat and explain your
concerns is the right thing for you to
do is go talk to the local media and
basically say look at what's going on
come see our school it's terrible so
it's almost like you make the the
politician the bureaucrat feel guilty is
it about taking your local politically
active person and they go with you to
the politician who says hey if you want
votes next year you better fix this
problem that's how democracy works
which of these means would work and
that's an example of two or three
different ideas and the way we do it is
and that brings me to the implement
stage you know the devil really is in
the details you can design something but
I often think we underestimate how much
implementation is challenging and so I
gave you three or four examples what we
would do is we would figure out with a
local organization so in this case we
are gonna work with local NGOs who know
how to implement things and say in this
context what is the right way to
implement this idea okay but we're still
not done even if you implement and even
if you have the best design and even if
you have the best diagnosis there's
never be arrogant right realize you
could be wrong yes and so what we do is
but Alaska culture in over
from part of the pint area so for us the
last two stages we call test and refine
which is setup and this is where
randomized control trial techniques or
other techniques can come in like if I
had four or five different ideas try all
of them in a scientific way then you can
test their relative effectiveness it's
running the permutation it's running the
permutations right it's when the
engineer starts running the machine and
gets lots of data to see how the machine
is running in different scenarios and
then the last step as you run the
machine as you test this as you test
these different policies new things will
emerge some things will succeed some
will not
and so the last step for us is refining
it's a constant iteration where you
learn from this first iteration about
what worked what didn't work you either
improve or stop doing what worked you do
more off and you get into more nuanced
ways of getting it to work so you would
take the different design that are being
implemented you would actually go and
work with a couple different schools and
a couple different methods absolutely
and then you would analyze how
successful those are and then continue
the ones that were successful maybe
refined some that weren't that's right
Steve thank you that's exactly right
and in fact my wish list for policy is
that that's how policy should happen all
policy should happen in this way now
it's challenging because remember a
politician or a leader doesn't want to
say I don't exactly know what to do but
I'll figure it out that's not a great
political slogan politicians and leaders
say I know exactly what to do vote for
me and I'll get your problem solved I
think so there's a dichotomy there
and my sense is look people want to hear
that I get it people want us here so I
think you can be honest
while not necessarily getting into the
details of things you can say I will fix
this but that doesn't mean sticking to a
specific policy I will fix this by
adapting or adopting a procedure or a
process which is a self-learning
correcting iterative process so even if
I start with my best guess which I think
may not be perfect I can improve every
single iteration I can get better and
better and better so over time I am
doing what I promised to you which is I
am fixing the problem right but I think
we have a tendency of not only saying
we're fixing the problem but also giving
the solution at the same time
and then we get stuck because if our
solution isn't the right solution we
have one or two choices admit that the
solution was wrong and change it or just
stick to it and most of us just stick to
it and hope the next guy is going to
come up and say well it was a perfect
solution but he screwed it up
so I hope that we can get more nuanced
and how we do policy and that's
something I would like not only for us
at CID but at the Kennedy School to
spread but also kind of teach amongst
our students and practitioners welcome
this act of saying set up the right
processes become learning States in fact
I'm I'm hoping to write a beginning to
write a book with a colleague of mine
Adnan and a couple of other colleagues
as well on how do we do evidence-based
decision-making in the policy space
we're gonna call it something like
learning States but the idea is to
really set up this this kind of learning
iterative process yes yes okay so now
that you've laid out speedy for us and
given us the idea of evidence and I
should say one other thing I wanted to
mention two other lives building state
capabilities which is at CID it does an
amazing thing called PDI a problem
driven iterative adaptation which is
very similar to speedy same ideas and
then growth lab which is headed by
Ricardo Hausmann which also has a very
interesting diagnostic approach a more
macro approach but basically says what's
the binding constraints and an economy
faces and how do i alleviate those
constraints so so I do want to say that
a lot of us are overlapping a lot we may
use different terms and words but I
think there's a general agreement that
our approach is very analytical
iterative self-learning corrective so
that feature is not inherent to speedy
yes
it's shared by all of us yeah yeah okay
cool cool and it totally makes sense
running the permutations analyzing which
ones are doing the best and continuing
to go to different pockets of the world
to continue testing these policy designs
now I want to know with the Center for
International Development what what
exactly is the kind of this future
roadmap is taking this process that
you've described and applying it across
more places in the world and empowering
people to get the process in and then
applying it is that kind of I think
that's it yeah I mean it's very much
taking it so two things one the approach
and the other the convening power
that we are lucky enough to have over
here so Edie you know if I if I were to
believe in my own process I should admit
that this approach is iterative as well
there's lots of learning in this so what
I'm giving you is my initial thing but I
want to be scientific and how I do
policy as well right so I'm starting
with what my best guess is my best guess
is we have an amazing ability to bring
people together we should use that gift
and the the responsibility we have is to
make sure that matching is happening in
the best possible way so we get the best
possible talent whether it's at Harvard
or elsewhere we get the most needy
people when I say needy people I mean
people dealing leaders or citizens
dealing with really pressing problems in
the world and we try and put the two
together so that's that convening aspect
and then once you come together how do
we bring them together what do we do
when we come together and that's very
much this approach which is and when I
say the approach I mean the meta version
of the approach not the specific look
everyone's gonna be doing speedy I mean
I might personally love that to say look
speedy is happening everywhere but it's
more than meta of the approach which is
people are willing to be in learning
environments people are willing to set
up learning systems the specifics of how
they do it is up to them
we can give some ideas but I think the
idea that I can design something I can
diagnose it properly I can iterate I may
be wrong I need to experiment this kind
of thinking is critical right failure is
not a problem like what we often think
of failure is like a terrible terrible
thing the terrible thing is is ignoring
failure when it happens and not learning
from it that's terrible right and so
just getting people comfortable with
that kind of way of thinking I think
that's the meta so if I even succeed in
a bit of this and you know there'll be
another leader at CID all I hope is that
that journey I'm stepping on people's
shoulders I would love it if in a few
years I'm ready to step down and someone
else is emerging who's taking this idea
to its next level so then would it be
fair to say that you really care a lot
about identifying the act two key actors
within the areas of the world that you
want to make help make policy design
permutations and and scientific analysis
within you need find those key actress
put them together especially from
different socioeconomic status is
different backgrounds different post
some and political office some of that
Education office that type of stuff okay
okay and actually find a requires the
onus on me if this thing works they come
themselves right if you succeed in what
they're doing people recognize it and
then people were like where should i if
i have a really pressing problem and i
want to work in this learning iterative
way where do i go and they'll be like
hey the cid at the Kennedy School yeah I
know they've done it and so you know
they start approaching us and then all
you need to do is basically just help
match them right you don't need to go
out and kind of the best sort of signal
that you're working is whether others
want to do what you're doing both in
terms of joining you and even
replicating what you're doing yes yes
yes
okay great that that does seem like a
really strong way you build out the
process season and people reach out and
you can pair people together and make
the change this is awesome I'm so
excited for Center for International
development's to continue making the
impact and also to for us as a
simulation to be able to continue coming
and talking to the different leaders you
mentioned so many of them throughout the
conversation for us to be able to sit
down and dive deep into what's happening
in India or Indonesia and though it's a
difficult just amazing people yeah let's
get deeper into the exact nuance of the
gap of what how it's actually happening
is well okay just two quick questions on
the way out that we like asking our
guests on our show do you think we are
in a simulation is this a simulation I
don't know I mean there's a deep
question of areas life a simulation that
we live in I used to have a teacher who
was teach something called phenomenology
which is everything we experience is an
illusion and they may be multiple
illusions that you're experiencing but
for me personally no I think this is
very well I think everything we say
everything we and I you and I have
talked about from my purse
that is very well and it's something I
want to commit to acting on and I hope
you do and I hear your audience does and
so on yes yes in some grand scheme of
things it could be an elaborate
simulation but yeah because at the very
end of taking action on all of these
pressing challenges you at the very end
get to see how many levels you gain how
much experience you gave yeah so you
have to take these challenges on and
build up the skills yeah yeah and the
very last question we like asking is
what is the most beautiful thing in the
world to me I guess to me the most
beautiful thing is when I see someone
deploying their talent whatever that may
be for doing something which goes beyond
themselves yeah that's profound I like
that a lot
yeah and that's in many ways what the
processes that you're implementing do
enables people to self actualize and
then self transcend as well and what I
like about that is it doesn't matter who
you are where you are how rich you are
how poor you are our talented you are I
fundamentally believe each one of us has
some beautiful thing inside them which
they can give maybe just a smile you
know yeah different colors on color
wheels some smile some race kids some
build the billion-dollar organizes long
as you're going beyond yourself is going
beyond itself I love it awesome thank
you so much for coming on their show and
sitting down with us teaching us about
all this
thank you hopefully everyone that
watched thank you so much we greatly
appreciate it please check out the links
below we'll have all the links evidence
for policy design center for economic
research and Pakistan Centre for
international development and go and
talk to more people about these types of
processes of economic development around
the world to talk to your friends your
family online on social media with your
coworkers let's get more people
researching this and effectively being
able to implement economic development
strategies and also support the artists
entrepreneurs and organizations around
the world that you believe in help them
scale simulations links are below help
us out as well and
go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world
thank you so much for tuning in and we
will see you soon thank you peace
that's it awesome thank you so much
really appreciate